[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEAN-BAPTISTE HIRONDE: When I
started my company with my two
friends, I decided to create
edjing, the first free DJ
app for the large public.
The idea came from a passion.
I used to practice DJing
during student parties,
and at this time, I didn't
find a very easy to use
and affordable
solutions for mixing.
Today, we have more than
60 million downloads.
edjing is the most
downloaded DJ app.
We are present in 182 countries,
so I'm very proud of my team.
When we launched
our app on Android,
it became the largest
contributor for our growth.
We earn 50% of our revenues
on the Android platform
and more than 70% of our new
downloads come from Android.
SEVERINE PAYET: Our mission
is to provide great music
tools for music lovers.
We think that what made our
success possible in Android
is the fact that we
really put effort
in designing great and
quality apps for our users.
And this was also possible
thanks to the tools
that Google Play is
providing to publishers.
Material Design was
a great improvement
for our design team.
It was a more unified
and smooth experience.
It made them really discover
and love the Android world.
Audio latency is really
important for us.
We are designing
music applications,
so it has to be very
responsive and very reliable.
For DJ apps, you need the
latency to be very, very low.
DAMIEN DELEPINE: The
[INAUDIBLE] latency
is the audio gap between the
time we generate the sound
and when the sound actually
comes out of the speaker.
On the new Android
Marshmallow devices,
like Nexus 9, Nexus
5X, and Nexus 6P,
we are down 20
milliseconds of latency.
Thus we were able to
provide an application more
stable and more reactive so it's
usable for DJ professionals.
SEVERINE PAYET: We developed
Mixfader this year.
It lets you mix and
scratch directly
from your smartphone or
tablet via Bluetooth.
DAMIEN DELEPINE: And Android
Marshmallow developers
are able to be part of these big
negotiations between an Android
device and Mixfader.
Other platforms add a
minimum of 20 milliseconds
for their Bluetooth connections.
We were able to reach 7.5
milliseconds of latency.
We have the best experience
on the Android platform.
SEVERINE PAYET: We initially
had a premium business model,
but we started testing the
advertising model working
with AdMob.
We multiplied our
revenues by two to three,
depending on the app.
We love Google Play, because
we can interact with our users.
When they come in to leave
a review on the store,
we can answer to them directly.
And we can upload
and update very fast.
That's something that's
a real asset for us.
JEAN-BAPTISTE HIRONDE: Today
DJiT is the 10th largest music
app publisher, and
our ambition is
to be the number one
within the next two years.
Thanks to the audio latency
improvement on Android,
we're able to develop
new music apps for users,
and we can't wait for this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]